- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video is
get some practice adding
multiple digit numbers,
but the point of it, isn't
just to get the answer,
but to understand why the
method we use actually works.
So we're going to add 40,762 to 30,473.
And you can pause the video and
try to solve it on your own,
but I encourage you to watch this one
because it's really about
understanding how things happen.
So what I'm going to do is first,
think of this in terms of place value.
So let me write out my
place values, let's see,
this goes all the way up
to the ten thousands place.
So let's see ten thousands
and then we have a thousands,
then we have a hundreds--
I could write these words
out but this is a little bit
faster to write it this way.
And then we could have a tens place
and then we can have a ones place.
I wanna do that in a different color.
So then we have a ones place.
Let me make a table here
and I'm gonna express
both of these numbers
in terms of ten thousands, thousands,
hundreds, tens, and ones
and then I'm gonna, at the same time,
use what's sometimes known
as the standard method
or the standard algorithm.
Algorithm is a fancy word for a system,
a way of doing something.
But let's first represent these numbers.
Here I have four ten thousands.
One, two, three, four.
Here I have three ten thousands.
One, two, three,
I'm gonna add these two
together eventually.
In both of these numbers,
I have zero thousands,
so I have nothing in
this column right now.
Here, I have seven hundreds.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Here I have four hundreds.
One, two, three, four.
Then I go to the tens place,
here I have six tens.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Here I have seven tens.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
And then last, but not
least, here I have two ones.
One, two.
And here I have three ones.
One, two, three.
Now, let's just rewrite
this number up here,
this is four ten thousands,
so this is forty thousand,
I have zero thousands.
Right over there.
And then I have seven hundreths.
Seven hundreds.
I have six tens.
Six tens.
And I have two ones.
I'm just rewriting the number,
but let me write the
tens in that blue color.
So six tens and then two ones.
Having trouble switching colors.
Two ones.
So there you have it.
This and this are just different ways of
representing the same number
and then this down here, I
have three ten thousands,
and then I have zero thousands,
I have four hundreds here
and then I have seven tens,
seven tens,
and then I have three ones.
And so now, let's add up everything.
So I can add it here and then I can also
add up things right over here.
So in the standard method,
we would start at the lowest place,
and we'd say okay, two
ones plus three ones
is equal to five ones,
and similarly, two ones
plus three ones would be
one, two, three, four, five ones.
Fair enough, nothing fancy there.
Now let's go to the tens place.
Well, in the tens place we have six tens
plus seven tens, and
in the standard method
what you say is, "that's 13 tens,"
but 13 tens is the same
thing as three tens
and one hundred.
So what you do is, you would regroup.
You would say, "hey
look, this is three tens
"and one hundreds."
Sometimes people say, "Oh
you're carrying the one.
"Six plus seven is 13, carry the one."
And it seems somewhat magical,
but all you're doing is
you're taking ten of the tens
and you're regrouping it as a hundred.
It'll be a little clearer here.
So we have six tens and
then we have seven tens,
you add 'em all together,
you get one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, ten, eleven,
twelve, thirteen tens.
All we're doing right
over is we're saying,
"Look this is equal to a hundred."
So let's just convert that
into a hundred right over here.
Let's just convert that
and so what we do is,
we just write the three in the tens place
and then we add an extra
one in the hundreds place.
And so what are we gonna have
in the hundreds place now?
And actually, let me do it here
because it's a little more interesting.
So I have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, ten, eleven, twelve hundreds.
So I can write 'em down here.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten,
eleven and twelve,
but with the same thing,
we don't have a digit for
the number twelve in our
traditional number system,
so what I could do is I
could take ten of these
and I can convert is to a thousand.
So I'm gonna take ten of those
and give myself a thousand.
No we're gonna do the
exact same thing over here.
One plus seven plus four is twelve.
So you'd write--
That's two hundreds because
this is twelve hundreds,
that's two hundreds plus a thousand,
so we just regrouped again.
Now in the thousands place,
one plus zero plus zero is one thousand
and you see that right over
here, you have one thousand.
And then finally, in
the ten thousands place,
four ten thousands plus
three ten thousands
is seven ten thousands.
Four ten thousands plus
three ten thousands
is one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven ten thousands.
And so this number is 71,235.
71,235.
So hopefully it all makes sense
how these two things will fit together.
That what's going on over here--
You're not just magically carrying numbers
or magically regrouping,
you're just representing
the same number in different ways.